okay so before this started I said what
was this one called it's like how could
I forget the title sorry this is Mystery
Train and it's exactly what sounds like
it's Finn's birthday so Jake takes him
out train and it's got taken to the
birthday present but then people start
dying and leaving very humorous
skeletons
so eventually Finn decided he wants to
solve the case and he goes around
everybody gets killed different place
with skeletons including Jake it turns
out he thinks it's the conductor the
incredibly creepy conductor and it is
kind of sorta it was actually Jake all
along as the conductor and this was all
part of the fun little game actually
that is on it's the adventure time
version of the game isn't it we think
about it you ever seen that movie I just
totally ruin the ending for you awesome
so yeah and then the train goes off a
cliff and it's caught by jell-o mold and
they live happily ever after
um okay honestly I
my favorite part actually is seeing the
skeletons of the grin like I like when
the donut is about to get killed I'm
like okay what does this get of a donut
look like it was actually a really good
design I love the way like the mouth the
star came around and there actually is
something I like about trains or like my
piercing spirit in a way is just when
they're on the train there's just there
for lack of a better term there is
something kind of mysterious about
trains there is just a nice atmosphere
to them so I thought I was really gonna
like this one and it's just it's okay I
like some of the mystery cliches they
give away you know what can't be the
first person you suspect because it's
never that it can't be the train
conductor because he's too creepy it's
not a lot of Scooby Doo mysteries you
know that they can't make fun of while
it turns like the mystery cliches it's
about it can't think of too much else
for it how many trains have you actually
been on couple really there's mystery
there okay okay look all this in the
weird okay okay like yeah what is their
story okay what is the story behind them
okay going is that mystery going to the
city one day mean my friends fun just
like garbage bag full of beer and when I
say beer I don't mean beer bottles just
beer like just the liquid just the
liquid where did it come from its
mysterious and wonderful it's like a
gift from Santa I was underage and I
couldn't drink yeah I bet that did stop
it
no I got a raging good drink at some
point - that doesn't mean anything we're
not supposed to admit we do bad things
on here and that dude did and I regret
all of it
I don't okay uh no I actually completely
agree this is one of my least liked out
of all the episodes that I've ever seen
because it was kind of you could come
tell exactly what was gonna happen and
what was gonna go on and everything and
yeah I even said the beginning of like
is this the gift is the mystery the gift
you know and and that's the problem
considering how adventure time always is
off-the-wall and bizarre and it's hard
to kind of figure out where they're
going it's kind of weird when they
throwing one that's like so by the
numbers it's just kind of like a real
letdown at least it was to me there were
some fun parts like I love when Finn
woke up thought he was blind then when
he's like no here's your gift and it's
like oh my god a red a red blood or an
orange blindfold this is great yeah like
I mean there's definitely still some
funny moments and I like even with
switching the skeletons out it's like
yeah how could he do that throughout the
whole thing you know and I like sort of
the explanation of Oh Jake becoming the
conductor is just this little bit of him
goes - yeah into the of the train and
then turns into the conductor you know
so it's I think there's definitely some
fun things but you're right there's a
for something like adventure time that
it's just so you could never predict
where it's going and here it's like for
a few minutes you can know what its
gonna do where it's gonna go and I mean
you can't predict all the jokes but yeah
at the same time it's like yeah you kind
of get a general idea for it in a field
so yeah just cerva yeah I mean I can't
say I hate it or anything buzzer with
you sort of my least light yeah so it's
now the show this episode did introduce
something that is now gonna be a regular
the new sword
yeah hit serve like this branch thing at
the end Annette no you probably didn't
notice a few episodes when Finn got
pummeled his sword his gold one actually
goes flying into the forest and he
hasn't used it since how so now he has a
new sword that is so weird because like
most other shows would make like a big
thing about that Val him like making the
sword or even maybe a story behind the
sword but now it's just like he has a
new one yeah
that's kind of cool you know again just
little details like that or Candide
that's don't worry yeah I can I want to
defend it a lot but I really really
can't
I mean besides like you said these
skeletons especially the donut yeah I
mean I really was like looking forward
to what the skeleton but don't know it's
gonna look like it really didn't
disappoint it's like I could have
guessed that's what it would look like
yet you know it'd be really funny if
like one of them shaped like let's say
like whatever the king became one like
you know if the lights went off and the
skeleton came up it was like a totally
different scale tails like one of like
an ape or something like that it's like
how could something I got have that kind
of skeleton but maybe there to be
predictable and if you're fitting for
this episode the stupid stupid episode
which I don't like I hate all of it
every single second I didn't say that
community
that was him well we're not supposed to
admit the bad things we do and you know
what I just admitted that I totally lied
about an episode I actually just think
it's okay it's not even a good lie yeah
cuz it'd be more I'd be a better life I
like really loved it and just said I
hate it but no I just think it's okay
but what did this episode also do finish
now thirteen did they say is actually
yeah in the the tree-trunks episode no
no I mean oh okay so they said okay they
said he was twelve years so many S's
birthday assuming that we have missed
you know or we have not missed any other
birthdays um yeah that's right so that
would explain why his voice is getting
deeper to that's that's mark I always
like to see an animated show do that we
rely
as the voice actor especially of the you
know especially if it's a kid gets older
like the actual character gets me yeah I
really want to see them but it's a
strange show to do it in but it's like
I'm glad they're actually doing that
that's actually really cool well but too
bad it wasn't kind of a real letdown of
an episode yeah but but in a way I guess
it's kind of clever because it's like
yeah you gotta keep watching you don't
know what little tidbits were gonna drop
here there you gotta see them all you
know so like every single thing it's
like in like the final episode it's
gonna be like I'll be revealed you know
by that candy cane in the Mystery Train
episode what yeah did you see that once
damnit you gotta go back as we watch or
something so yeah I don't know so it's
uh not one my favorites but you know not
terrible by any means you know just
predictable yeah just especially for a
mystery not well played
not well played at all no so you wanna
play clue that'd be awesome
can I be the murderer yeah sure
wait a minute no we're not supposed to
know that ahead of time are we it's more
fun that way
yes sure what the hell you can be the
body can we pick someone else if only
all its I guess you fine wait where's
your cat there is I don't I have no part
in this don't don't get peed on me don't
get peed on you